MORE UNHAPPY THEY SEEM.
WITH REAL ANSWERS JOINED BY
LARRY KUDLOW, WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
ECONOMIST ADVISOR.
CONGRATS ON THE HUGE JOB
NUMBERS.
I HAVE KNOWN YOU FOR 25 YEARS.
I DIDN'T KNOW IF HE WE WOULD SIT
HERE WITH NUMBERS LIKE THIS
TONIGHT.
IT BLOWS AWAY REAGAN'S NUMBERS.
>> I WON'T GO THAT FAR.
>> Laura: LARRY KUDLOW SAYING
TRUMP'S RECOVERY NOT AS GOOD AS
REAGANS.
>> I WOULD NOT SAY THAT EITHER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLICIES TO
REBUILD THE ECONOMY PUT US INTO
A POWERFUL PROSPERITY BOOM.
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT.
LOW TAX RATES.
ENERGY OPENINGS AND TRADE
REFORMS.
GROWTH, GROWTH, GROWTH.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GOT GOING HERE.
THESE BLOW OUT NUMBERS.
IT'S ABOUT A FORTNIGHT.
IT STARTED WITH A GDP NO ONE
BELIEVED POSSIBLE.
TODAY THE JOBS BEAT ESTIMATES
ABOUT 70,000.
I WAS GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE THE
LAST TIME WE HAD 3.6.
>> Laura: IT'S A TIGHT LABOR
MARKET.
THAT MEANS WAGES ARE GOING UP.
I READ TODAY IN THE JOURNAL THAT
ROCKWELL CORPORATION, THEY ARE
TRAINING AMERICAN VETERANS TO DO
THE JOBS.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BRING IN
FOREIGN WORKERS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE
SIDELINES COMING BACK INTO THE
ECONOMY.
>> ONE OF THE OTHER BLOW OUT
NUMBERS WAS THE PRODUCTIVITY,
HOW EFFICIENT ARE WE.
SOARING TO 2.4%.
TO YOUR POINT WHICH IS REALLY
GOOD, WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
ESTIMATES VAR.
THERE MAY BE 25 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO LEFT THE LABOR
FORCE BECAUSE THEY WERE
DISCOURAGED.
THEY ARE COMING BACK.
THEY ARE COMING BACK BECAUSE THE
RAGE WAITS ARE MOVING ABOVE 3%
AND BECAUSE THEIR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS ARE GOING BACK TO
WORK.
THEY ARE COMING BACK BECAUSE
THESE COMPANIES NEED THEM.
IF YOU ARE NOT TOTALLY
QUALIFIED, THEY WILL RE-TRAIN
YOU.
AS MY COLLEGE IVANKA TRUMP PUTS
IT, THEY WILL RE-SKILL YOU.
>> Laura: SHE IS REALLY PUSHING
THAT AND I AM GLAD.
WE ARE SEEING --
>> HIGHER WAGES BRING THEM IN.
>> Laura: EVERYONE SHOULD BE
THRILLED ABOUT WAGES GOING UP.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO WEIRD,
THE WASHINGTON MAINSTREAM
ECONOMISTS HIGHER WAGES ARE BAD
AND CAUSE INFLATION.
NONSENSE!
MORE PEOPLE WORKING AND
PROSPERING.
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED.
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS ARE THE
WINNERS.
A STAT FOR YOU --
>> Laura: DON'T TELL ME THE
STATS.
>> MY FRIEND JOE BIDEN SAID THE
MIDDLE-CLASS IS NOT
PARTICIPATING.
THE LOWER 25% OF THE INCOME
EARNERS THEIR WAGE IS UP 4.5%.
UPPER 25, 3%.
THEY ARE BOTH RISING.
>> Laura: I LOVE THAT.
EARLIER TODAY CNN'S JACK TAPPER
YOUR OTHER FRIEND SAID THIS
ABOUT WHY THE BOOMING ECONOMY IS
NOT LEAD HIS SHOW.
>> WE WERE GOING TO LEAD WITH
THE ECONOMY.
WE WERE GOING TO SING THE
NUMBERS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKED TO VLADIMIR PUTIN WITH
THE RUSSIAN HOAX.
>> JAKE IS A FRIEND BUT SHOULD
HAVE LED WITH THE ECONOMY.
WAGES AND BOOMING GROWTH, AND
PRODUCTIVITY, MORE PEOPLE
EMPLOYED.
LOOK, NO INFLATION.
>> Laura: THE EXPERTS PREDICTED
AND PREDICTED RESIGNATION.
EVEN BLOOMBERG SAID NO INFLATION
INSIDE.
INFLATION NUMBERS TOO.
THAT MAY GIVE THEM GROUNDS.
>> Laura: DON'T SOFTEN UP ON
CHINA.
THE CHINA POLICY IS WORKING.
NO SOFTENING UP ON CHINA.
>> THE NEGOTIATORS ARE SCARED OF
YOU.
THEY WON'T BACK OFF.
>> Laura: GREAT.
>> IT'S GOT TO BE A GREAT DEAL
WITH CHINA.
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T TRADE WITH
THE SOPHISTICATED.
-- SOVIET UNION.
WHY TRADE WITH CHINA?
YOU ARE NOT ANSWERING MY CHINA
QUESTION.
>> LISTEN TO ME, THERE COULD BE
100 BILLION DOLLARS OF ADDED GDP
IF BOBWHITE DOES A GOOD JOB.
PEOPLE WON'T GIVE TRUMP ANY
CREDIT.
EVERYTHING IS CONVERGING.
THIS IS A POWERFUL PROSPERITY
WAVE.
>> Laura: THEIR ARGUMENT IS
TRUMP IS NOT A GOOD PERSON.
HE TWEETS TOO MUCH.
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO IGNORE THE
FACT THAT THE ECONOMY IS GREAT
AND FOCUS ON OTHER ISSUES.
THEY WILL MAKE IT LIKE A
PERSONALITY CONTEST.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE.
JOE BIDEN USING THE WORD DIGNITY
A LOT.
A LOT OF DIGNITY IN THESE
NUMBERS.
>> HE IS A GOOD PERSON.
>>.
>> Laura: HE LEFT A CUSHY
BUSINESS TO GET BEAT UP
EVERYTHING.
>> LOOKING AHEAD TO THE
ELECTION, WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DEVELOP THE BIGGEST, BIG TENT
ECONOMIC COALITION IN HISTORY.
PROBABLY LIKE REAGAN IN 1984.
THE TAX CUTS ARE WORKING AND THE
TRADE IS WORKING.
>> Laura: AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CITING INCOME AND ECONOMY.
>> IT'S THE BLUE COLLAR WORKERS
DOING THE BEST.
THEIR WAGE GOING UP IS THE
FASTEST.
I WANT TO SIT DOWN WITH MY
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS AND WALK
THROUGH THESE NUMBERS.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THEIR PLAN TO
RAISE THE STANDARD OF LIVING FOR
AMERICANS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH.
THOSE DEMOCRATS THAT WANT TO GO
TO THE SOCIALISTS DIRECTION,
THEY COULD TURN THIS PROSPERITY
CYCLE INTO A MAJOR DOWN TURN.
POVERTY WOULD WIN AND NOT
PROSPERITY.
THAT'S A BIG THEME HERE.
NO TO SOCIALISM.
IT'S NO GOOD.
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL, THE NEW
GREEN DEAL IT WILL WRECK THIS
PROSPERITY.
THE PRESIDENT IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE ENTIRE ECONOMY AND THAT'S
IMPROVING.
WE WILL GO TO EVERY NOOK AND
CRANNY TO BRING PROSPERITY IN.
>> Laura: MAKE THE TRIPS TO
OAKLAND AND CHICAGO.
DON'T BE DEPERT.
>> WE WILL GO.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: GREAT TO SEE YOU.TERRD
>> Laura: GREAT TO SEE YOU.TERR.
>> WE WILL GO.
ABSOLUTELY.